mike
some new hot fire for you
flat earther rap oh this is our boy dr
bricks this is
eric dube oh eric dube is one of owen
benjamin's foils
it's one of his uh uh arch nemesis
msi nemesis star trek nemesis nemesis
it's called 200 proofs rap i bet it's
good
[Music]
oh by the way we just mentioned flat
earth and they like flat earthers have
this extra magnet in their nose and they
know it
so now they're all going to show up
yeah we'll prove it's round i don't know
the [ __ ] pictures
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
oh i'm sorry but have you ever been to
space
no that would be very expensive for us
all to go to space and look
this is terrible y'all see us the
distraction below what's happening
all right sami zayn you're not fooling
me buddy wait is did the song start
yeah do you hear what his shirt says
nope
nope
y'all say it's a distraction below
what's happening truth is take it to the
streets with the plan of action why
would they
wait what no no
no this is real no
oh this is real he's just mumbling this
is really weird
he sounds like zombie the genie from pee
wee herman [ __ ]
he sounds like he got punched in the
face two seconds ago
and said i gotta finish the song anyway
show has to go on he looks like he just
lost a knockout game
and by the way have you heard of putting
i don't know a ceiling in
by the way kanye west literally had his
jaw
wired shut and wrapped better than this
just [ __ ] amazing
yo what's the point man it is what it is
well how you think those characters
navigate to see
it's easy as plane trigonometry
dude i'm not kidding you if you guys get
a chance
after today's show go and listen to
through the wire
by kanye west the man got in a car
accident they wired his jaw shut
and he said you know be great [ __ ] it
i'll do a song with my jaw watch
who's ever done that before and it was
fire
compared to the right it was a good
through the wire is actually
one of my favorite kanye west songs and
this guy
obviously has full use of his face and
he's just like
it's just that word
here's the thing so like even if you
believe flat earth
this is objectively a bad rap song like
even if
so look guys listen flat earthers let's
little truce here
i get it you want to believe the earth
is flat i got it ice wall whatever fine
can we agree this is a bad rap song can
we at least agree on that
yes ask any surveyor or architect
if there's a liquid curvature that they
can detect even civil engineers see we
ain't on a sphere
ask pilots what they see when they up in
the air
probably the sky i don't know i mean i'm
assuming
yeah that and the [ __ ] flask they
have in their jacket pocket
and that [ __ ] flight attendant's ass
i'll tell you what they see everything
double
exactly i've never known i'm sure he's
the same for you
i have never known a pilot that's not an
alcoholic i've never met one
ask would the pilot see when they're in
the air they see the
series of buttons that they push to make
the plane fly itself
while they take a nap in the cabin
saying that we're all monkeys and here's
the thing like if you do ask a pilot in
a pi
this is the flat earthers it's
impossible at arguably i don't do it
anymore
but if you if you if you were to ask
them what do you see well yeah no i
actually do see the curvature when i'm
flying they go [ __ ] nasa's chill
you're a shill bro and you can see it if
you go up to cruising altitude yeah
you can see it like i feel like some of
these people have only taken
small domestic flights before like you
know
if you fly let's say from new york to
miami you go over the ocean
and there's and you go way up and if you
look out you
you can actually see it yes yeah they've
only been on planes that are piloted by
balloon kid cloud kicker
if we don't belong we're like with some
kind of disease now have you ever seen a
river running uphill that's what i
thought
and you never know because there's this
thing called no no let me allow me royce
okay so gravity
which is the force uh
um of like pushing down towards the
earth see
large celestial bodies have this force
called
gravity which is why um if you
you know i mean this is why things fall
downward
you want a nail in the coffin i'm sure
you can have it take a good look at the
second law thermal dynamics
we got 200 and i don't mean to be a dick
here
yes you do fair enough i do
have you ever met a cool flat earther
like have you seen one single one of
these flat earthers where you're like
that guy would be cool frankie b flat
baby
seriously i'm asking think of one can
anyone name
i i will welcome one on the show
if you guys can find us one
cool flat earther we're not accepting
answers of me
one cool flat one cool prominent flat
earther
that you've ever seen and dumped uh
demonic terrorists know they're all
aside i know some people that are cool
as [ __ ] i think you can agree right
i'm pretty rude but yeah we know some
absolute
dumb asses that are [ __ ] cool and fun
to hang out with right
joe coletta joe coletta john sanzari
he's not exactly a rhodes scholar
but we've never once had john sanzari
say you want to hang out and been like
we don't want to hang out with you
we're always like oh yeah johnny boy
yeah let's go hang out with johnny boy
like name one person who believes in
flat earth that you've ever seen on
youtube where you go
that's a guy i would want to have a beer
with they're all [ __ ]
dorks you know who else jj stoner
love that guy and i think he would own
up to that he'd be like oh yeah man hey
look i ain't getting
accepted in harvard anytime soon i love
it
but if if [ __ ] jj were in town and
goes here you guys want to hang out
we'll be like [ __ ] clear on my schedule
let's go we're
going to go have a beer boys boys boys
boys boys
you got lights look at these guys come
on
what if it comes out like ryan long
calls this later and goes like yeah hey
man i'm actually flattered
don't say anything because that would be
amazing
[ __ ] no we need you to come on the show
to prove that there's one cool platter
[Music]
if ryan long ever said that to us like
yeah dude i'm a flat earther he'd pull
you aside and go
did the check i'm with it's just flat
earth she's just [ __ ] just
just play along all right yeah man why
don't you see the curvature dude
[Laughter]
louis jay gomez would be the same way
yeah donkey but look i've been in a
plane i don't ever see the [ __ ]
dude dude just play along man this chick
wants to blow me later
you got lights in the sky
and then [ __ ] jesse from pod awful
comes out and goes can you believe what
a simp right along is he
lied about the curvature of the earth to
get [ __ ]
off that cannon this rhyme's tighter
than a dry hymen vagina
your mind's kinda like a fine china
chinning i don't know okay this is this
is worse
this is this is worse this guy's worse
that that's if if you did that as a
joke i would be laughing at you
please go back to this
oh i got you
[Music]
questions
always sunny he might be there's a lot
of them holy [ __ ] dude there's a great
deal of mcqueen ryan stop
somebody
[Laughter]
suggestion what shapes the world is it
twirling around you reckon wait tha is
that eric debay
is that i don't know who is eric the bay
is this the guy city smoke said that's
because it's eric dubai
is that is this eric to be i've never
seen him i've heard his name
probably five million times well let's
round let's make it six
i've heard his name six million times
only through owen benjamin's circles is
that
eric dubay yes oh god
i think i'm teemo and benjamin again
this guy is
jesus christ
take a second you're gonna need a
physics lesson you've been taught that
you ought not to feel the spinning
but i've talked with a lot to repeal the
scene he looks like
you know when like a white trash person
has to dress up for court
exactly yeah i'm here from a dui
i had a little bit of meth too they said
they'll throw the meth charge out i just
copped to the
dui somebody says he looks more like
rickety cricket okay
oh god this is a nightmare i meant
being him must be a nightmare of course
it seems did you guys think that you're
gonna make this song and people are
gonna go holy [ __ ] man you know
[ __ ] man these guys are so cool maybe
the earth is flat he looks like he buys
all this dress clothes at sears
and ross yeah i gotta go to ross i gotta
get a clip-on tie for my trial
i mean the seam is crooked but it was 20
off i'm gonna get him to argue it down
probably take a plea because i didn't
know how old the kid was
[Laughter]
because on the ball this gradient's
involved it's not so simple
eric debay does look like one of those
guys that's on to catch a predator going
they were just
online chats they were just chat we were
just talking
on ph right at the equator with polar
observers sitting softly at nil
and everyone between at different speeds
still
[Music]
you got lights in the sky we've got 200
my name's frankie b flatt and i'm here
to say i bother people in the
supermarket every day
excuse me ma'am what's the greatest lie
you've ever been told
this old gang again you better stop or
you're gonna get a scold
all right and now i'm here
with some rhymes that are fiery while
you're researching flat earth red
diary that guy shows up too
oh they're all here again that's another
collabo dog it's another collabo dog
i love it where is gum chew and coach
flat earth guys
he's my favorite one he's actually you
know what i take it back i think that
flat earth guy
he might be i don't i don't have enough
conclusive evidence
but the guy covered a night wave with
gum chewing it wasn't the owen thing
that guy seems like he could possibly be
cool in the right situation
god damn dude guys my name's owen
benjamin i'm in my yard
that joe rogan guy's a real [ __ ]
sorry come on man take this seriously
hey at least
this is the place the only one that i
think would be good at this is eddie
bravo because he looks like someone that
would rap well
in other words no matter how the child
that can't move the earth is it on
pillars or balanced on elephants
questions like what's he saying
honestly i'm not trying to be a dick
here but
he doesn't open his mouth when he talks
again
i don't get to counter your point kanye
west couldn't
open his mouth during through the wire
and i understood everywhere he was
rapping
may seem like nonsense unless you're
willing to clear your mind of all that
propaganda they used to confine
your own logic and levels of reasoning
we're always hearing explain the season
see the sun moves itself on a circuit
between the tropics of cancer and
capricorn you heard of it how about the
spire top of notre dame [ __ ] captain
said
why don't you have a ceiling in your
house i mean that to me is probably
my biggest question because ceilings are
a
myth bro the [ __ ] trick dude right
just like flight
oh yeah the earth is round i need to
have ceilings
come on he's not gonna [ __ ] fall for
that [ __ ] dude
someone says you put your bessy michael
rappaport no just michael poor rapper
[Laughter]
150 miles away okay also said
elephants melophants jellyfish elephants
on the elephants
that's so bad this is so bad
this is so bad of course more toys
below the curve light refraction only
accounts for 12 for that yard they
changing the shape
to an old blade spheroid sounds like the
ramblings of a blow to schizoid
what why is this happening
it's [ __ ] right why is this xbox just
play xbox is playing the guitar leave
him alone dude
it looks like varg
[Music]
someone's going in for ma you know
frog to be in this video and he's like
no i'm not some [ __ ] loser
[ __ ] you dude are you kidding me what am
i a [ __ ] nerd
i have the atf surrounding my house
right now i don't have time for this
i've got a kid
all right jesus calm down
i love eve
[Music]
there you go it's 200 proofs
are you convinced now i'm convinced
these people